qu'est ce que tu veux exactement
j'ai envie des fluides mais si tu seras
la femme que tu as envie de devenir
elle a disparu je voulais savoir si vous
aviez ultime veille non elle a arrêté de
venir
c'est dommage d'ailleurs dans la grande
majorité des cas ces personnes qui
disparaissent choisissent de rester
l'introuvable le plus souvent parce
qu'elle fuit quelque chose excusez moi
je ne ferais pas être ici non non
sûrement pas le système de détention en
australie est le reflet de nos de nos
mesures d'accompagnement des
l'immigration qui nous permet de
déterminer à la fois l'identité des
demandeurs d'asile et la légitimité de
leurs différentes demandes de protection
vous commencez tous une nouvelle vie on
ne pouvait pas vous raccrocher au passé
[Musique]
et s'il vous plaît il doit y avoir une
erreur je ne suis pas un criminel des
endroits comme celui-ci a partout
australie
pourquoi parce qu'on a des terroristes
vous pouvez vous confirmer qu'une
citoyenne australienne a illégalement
étaient détenus ici à barton
beaucoup de gens qu'on s'intéressait à
toi ils voudront sûrement savoir comment
quelqu'un qui leur semble a pu se faire
piéger dans un endroit pareil
elle a disparu depuis des semaines et
vous n'avez toujours aucune piste et
vous pensez que ce groupe a quelque
chose à voir avec la disparition de
votre soeur c'est dangereux pour moins
de guerre qui est sûr c'est que plein de
gens meurent des familles s'en séparer
c'est de la seule chance qu'ils avaient
de pouvoir rester une famille et toi tu
les a privés un bed famille un homme de
confiance pourquoi vous ne voyez pas ça
en face de moi elle ne sait pas ce qu'on
est capable de faire pour ne pas mettre
un couvercle sur une amie qui est en
train de vivre
rien à faire si je suis désolé mais tant
que vous ne me dirai pas qui vous êtes
d'une partie du var
quelque chose un dessert si j'étais toi
je me ferais si je te rends compte
encore une fois je te tv
le monde entier doit savoir ce qu'on
nous fait subir ici on va bientôt leur
dire